the world is facing a big medical
problem
a growing number of patients
and not enough doctors to treat them
so could artificial intelligence be the
cure i feel like i'm working at the
forefront of something that could
potentially be revolutionary to
healthcare in the future ai has the
power to transform the ways patients are
diagnosed and treated when we think
it'll become a game changer and to make
the testing of new medical procedures
more efficient and effective if we can
get devices that can be developed faster
better
and quicker
then there are huge benefits
[Music]
elaine manor is blind in one eye
she is a victim of age-related macular
degeneration
the most common cause of blindness in
the uk and us
when it went to my other eye i was just
terrified i was in bits i was weeping in
the rain and
thinking i don't want to be here
[Music]
for years the threat of losing her other
eye has loomed large
until a successful treatment enabled the
thankful 75 year old to see her way to
some high wire fundraising
i did the high sick wire in europe
i did the sky dive
and then i did the the wing walk
[Music]
but the doctor who saved elaine's eyes
says she is one of the lucky ones nearly
10 of all clinic appointments in the nhs
are for eyes that's nearly 10 million
appointments per year so to put it
brutally we're almost drowning in the
number of patients we need to see
and as a result of that there are some
patients unfortunately who go blind
because of delays in being seen and
treated a pregnant mother was left
almost completely blind waiting for care
she has since given birth and has never
seen her daughter's
face dr keen
believes there's an answer
artificial intelligence
he and his partners have developed ais
which can diagnose over 50 types of eye
disease just as well as a doctor
but do so
much much more quickly the ai system can
analyze the retinal scans within seconds
and it can delineate all of the
different disease features on the scans
a human expert would probably take hours
or even days to complete the same task
ai can help to address a growing global
challenge
in 2020
an estimated 596
million people had distance vision
impairment worldwide
of whom 43 million were blind
by 2050 both these figures are set to
increase by approximately 50 percent
a task that can take specialist doctors
hours now being done in seconds through
artificial intelligence and it's not
just eyesight ai's ability to mine and
analyze patient data far more quickly
than humans can mean diagnoses could
improve in many areas of medicine we do
more than a thousand scans per day in
the hospital it's a challenge because
where do we get the the human experts to
be able to review all those scans but
it's also an opportunity because that
huge amount of data is the perfect
substrate for the development of
artificial intelligence systems
but there are concerns
in particular threats to the privacy of
patients
deepmind google's ai company and one of
dr keane's partners has found itself
under fire
google deep mind the search giant's
artificial intelligence arm may have
received the personally identifying
medical records of 1.6 million nhs
patients here at the royal fair hospital
on a legally inappropriate basis
unrelated to its work with dr keane
deepmind is currently facing legal
action over its use of nhs data
yet if data can be better protected
ai has the capacity to make patient care
much better
and more efficient
so we have a world that is essentially
very much connected
but yet healthcare data is siloed
we can order a taxi from almost anywhere
in the world using our smartphones
but yet if we have a patient who comes
to an eye hospital like moorefields but
they're also attending a hospital
because they've got cancer we often
can't easily connect their data
dr keen hopes his latest collaboration
with machine learning startup bitfont
could not only join data dots better but
also improve patient privacy with fount
is is a kind of switchboard all we do is
essentially pass messages between
someone who wants to ask something of
the data set and the owner of the data
the data
never never leaves its home location so
if that data is held by a hospital
no data ever leaves the hospital bitfont
says this technology could have other
benefits like approving new treatments
more quickly and safely patients are
losing out a lot by the fact that ideal
medical treatments for them are not
coming through to to market
with the extra technical guarantees that
privacy preserving techniques like
bitfont can provide there's been a real
feeling around the healthcare ecosystem
that that could speed up a lot of those
governance processes
by 2027
ai's value in the healthcare market is
expected to be eight times bigger than
in 2020 growth could also be boosted if
clinicians reduce their dependence on
coders and start to develop their own ai
systems
this is really exciting because today's
retinal experts have been unable to
identify gender dr kira o'bern is part
of a team of clinicians who have managed
to do what google brain did in 2018
develop ai that can recognize gender
from retinal scans
something no human can do
a member of our research group developed
a code-free deep learning model which
accurately identified gender from
rational images
this is incredibly exciting because by
positioning clinicians
to develop their own models
independently it could really open the
door to further discoveries in both
disease patterns and disease biomarkers
a new generation of doctors believe
empowering clinicians in this way will
bring them closer to patients
generally it's the clinician that's the
healthcare workers working face-to-face
with the patient to understand what the
patients need best
so therefore i believe that if we can
allow them to independently develop
their own tools this will allow the
patient to remain at the very forefront
of everything
it's the world's first hand-held
battery-powered computer able to hold
thousands of data points i think that
we're potentially at a tipping point a
little bit like the tipping point that
we saw in the late 1970s in the
computing industry we had the
introduction of the first personal
computers if you empower people with
this technology even if primitive in the
beginning they will come up with
hundreds or even thousands of
applications that the engineers would
never have thought of
but some are skeptical about pinning
hopes too fast on ai
the issue is that ai models are
essentially black boxes and so what
happens is that when they're working
well they're working well and no
questions are asked but what happens if
a wrong decision is made what happens
when something goes wrong and how do we
really trace that back and ensure
accountability and guarantee
interpretability if we're using these
black box models
while it is early days for ai in
medicine it could also improve the
testing of new medical devices
a long time ago
a million years bc
everything was
absolutely free
in 2021 former part-time singer and
model patricia walker had an artificial
valve inserted into her heart to save
her life i needed a new valve
because the one that i had wasn't
working it was dripping this is why i
was feeling
the pain that i was getting the
exhaustion and it it was getting
worse
although patricia's operation was a
success
it was not without risk and the
cardiologist who inserted the valve says
ai can make new technologies like this
safer for patients
by creating virtual trials
if we can plan a procedure by simulating
that procedure in an individual patient
in a computer-generated model before we
go to the patient then we can get a much
better outcome in the patient without
posing any risk to that patient at all
at the university of leeds dr blackman
is collaborating with professor alex
frangie he is using machine learning to
automate the building of
three-dimensional digital replicas this
is the real one
and this is the fake one
but it's very difficult to the naked eye
to to pick that up
virtual trials mean multiple variations
of a proposed new procedure or
technology can be tried out we can test
different scenarios of treatment on the
same
anatomy and physiology of a given
virtual individual and that's something
which is not again possible to do with
conventional trials
we're also comparing different scenarios
of hypertensive and normal tensive
conditions
virtual trials do not replace human
trials
but they do speed up the time and reduce
the money required to identify the right
devices and humans to test
in 2021 the team at the university of
leeds found their virtual trials
produced the same results as three
clinical trials but much more
efficiently
each of those studies took between six
and eight years to to be undertaken and
they probably cost around 20 to 30
million each of them so what we showed
is that in this computational study that
the execution of it took about three
months so
that's you know less than
20 grand
some working in the medical world
believe a bright future lies ahead as
ais become more sophisticated and more
capable
in other words more intelligent ai 1.0
in my view is the ability to automate
tasks that otherwise
could be very boring or time consuming
or repetitive
ai 2.0
is the one that actually tries to look
at incorporating prior information on
the physics on the physiology in a much
more intimate manner with the data so
it's not just data driven but it's also
knowledge driven for healthcare it's
hard to see a future without ai
i strongly believe that one day
artificial intelligence
will renew this eye
thanks for watching i'm tom standage
deputy editor of the economist to read
more of our coverage of ai please click
on the link don't forget to subscribe
you